there was a war coming history needs you
to be ready
these legends of tomorrow yeah yeah
[Music]
everybody we got a whole bunch of new
Wally West stuff to talk about on the
flash legends of tomorrow I also have
some details about Titan season 1 in
Young Justice season 3 that I'll talk
about at the end of the video - all on
top of the back that it's Super Bowl
Sunday there's a bunch of crazy trailers
dropping from all the big comic book
studios so the big stuff about wally
west he's actually coming on to legends
of tomorrow way sooner than we thought
now I thought it wasn't gonna be till
episode 13 that's what had been reported
by all the big press outlets but come to
find out he's actually coming on the
show for the first time in episode 11
which explains why he's not on the flash
TV show right now so I'm sort of
explaining the transition from him to
being a flash character to a legends
character then back to flash at the end
of the season so I know it sounds
confusing but what happens is is rip
hunter is the one that tracks him down
and grabs him to bring him to the team
but it sounds like he doesn't trust the
team right away because when they
originally reported that he was joining
the team in episode 13 what probably
happens is is that he shows up during
episode 11 with rip hunter just as
totally not down with their shenanigans
so goes off but then comes back to join
full-time so it's not like he's just
gonna show up everything's gonna be
awesome and then they'll go forward
it'll be a bit of a rough start and it's
in the transition from Constantine to
Wally West so Constantine when the show
comes back is episode 1011 sounds like
at the end of that episode Wally West
shows up then goes away then comes back
full time in episode 13 so it sounds
more complicated than it is but that
promo they tease a war is coming they
tease the malleus storyline so a lot of
that is from the next two episodes but
also a little bit after that there's
that
Hunter dialogue Murray says you need to
be ready you get a couple brief shots of
Wally West but they haven't released
like a really big Wally centric promo
and they'll probably wait to do that for
episode 13 because it still is mostly
Constantine for the next two episodes so
now it makes a little more sense why
Wally isn't able to immediately help out
Barry in the team and everything that's
going on with a thinker this season
because he's going to be pulled out of
time then brought back at the end of the
season the language that the producers
use is that he's not going back to the
flash in the near future so that means
that he'll go back before the end of the
season know why you can make it is
tumbler Valley believe but more power to
him hopefully that helps their ratings
I've always said that the flash
characters are so much more popular than
most of the other characters that it
just benefits them to put at least one
of the speedsters on the team per season
so even if Wally doesn't go back next
season they could always put Jesse quick
on the team they could put Jay Garrick
on the team that would actually be
pretty badass but speaking of which Jay
Garrick will be coming back to the flash
within the next two or three episodes
then there been a lot of rumors about
the new version of the reverse flash
showing up during episode 15 I wonder
what face I'll be wearing next time we
meet
can't wait I don't know if that's true
but we'll probably find out in the next
couple of weeks but the flash like a lot
of other TV shows is taking a brief
break after this next episode so it'll
be gone for the Olympics which most TV
shows are doing then it'll be back
legends of tomorrow is the exception to
that
it will air continuously with no breaks
so even though the Olympics will be
happening and everything goes on break
there will still be brand new legends
episodes every single week on Monday
nights remember it's a Monday night show
now speaking of premieres talking about
Titan season 1 premiere and Young
Justice season 3 premiere we've already
talked a little bit about Young Justice
premiering during the fourth quarter
that's anytime between October in
December but I just found out how they
plan to air episodes and it gives us a
pretty good idea of when Titan season 1
is going to premiere and it will not
surprise you at all you'll be like oh
yeah that totally makes sense
unofficially confirmed that they're
going to air episodes on the DC
streaming service for all the new TV
shows so that's Young Justice Titans the
Harley Quinn show whatever this new
Superman show ends up being once per
week just like you would watch the flash
arrow legends of tomorrow Supergirl any
of the other DC TV shows so one new
episode per week and because they want
to keep a steady stream of brand new
content coming out every week what
they'll do is after they air the Titans
finale then they'll start Young Justice
season 3 within a week that you know
timing is a bit ambiguous but right
after Titans Young Justice season 3
premieres so because the very earliest
The Young Justice season 3 could
premiere is October you just work 13
episodes once per week in Reverse and
you have your premiere day for Titans so
99% chance the Titans premieres and they
launched the DC streaming service
between the end of July in August just
to hit that date so that they can get
Young Justice season 3 out now obviously
there's a couple weeks for wiggle room
but what I think will happen is and a
lot of you have probably picked up on
this wait a minute what's happening at
the end of July why would they launch a
comic book show at the end of July
because Comic Con is July 19th to 22nd
so what they'll probably do is they'll
show the first episode of Titans at
Comic Con then after that just launch it
worldwide like they'll show off the new
series they'll do a big panel where
Geoff Johns explained
what's going on how they're gonna deal
with all the really big characters then
boom everybody gets to watch it but I
know everybody wants to know how do you
watch it especially if you're not in
North America in the DC streaming
service might not be available outside
of the United States so what'll probably
happen is is they'll announce some of
those details but do not worry whether
or not it's legal everybody around the
world will be watching it week to week
and of course I'll do billions of videos
it's gonna be a lot of fun I'm really
excited because it's gonna be so much
more hardcore than the stuff you've seen
so far and it seems like they have
access to the bigger characters that you
would never see on the other DC TV shows
like a version of Bruce Wayne they're
gonna do Trigon eventually that's
probably about as big as you could go so
it'll probably happen is is unless they
dramatically change their plans between
now and then we will see a trailer for
the series by April or May but I do
think it's gonna be a little while
longer because they haven't been filming
episodes for that long so no worries
everything should go according to plan
they'll make some more announcements
about the business model of it all like
the mechanics of how you actually watch
episodes and how they're gonna release
them but think HBO now if you watch Game
of Thrones on HBO now week to week it'll
probably be just like that
but just remember Young Justice season 3
is gonna be 26 episodes I of course will
also do videos for that so since that's
a little further off we'll probably get
some more information about that when we
get closer to comic-con we'll get a lot
more Titan stuff before we get Young
Justice stuff so just leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below
just a reminder Super Bowl Sunday is
tomorrow I'll do videos for as much
stuff as possible but be sure to leave
your requests in the comments there's a
new round of that blasts ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and share the video using the
tools on the watch page congratulations
to the winner from my last video
basketball taco please private message
me so I can get your contact details
click here for my brand new flash
trailer and click here for brand new
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight